- So, a little bit about myself
before we kinda jump into it.
Adrian Estala, as you
guys can read up here.
I'm the CDO at Starburst.
I was a CDO before I joined Starburst,
so oftentimes when I look at
these types of discussions,
it's not from a Starburst perspective,
it's from an ecosystem perspective,
and so I hope to kind of bring
to you a broader conversation
of strategy that includes Starburst.
So very nice to meet everybody.
Roger, why don't you tell us
about yourself?
- Yep. I am Raja Palaniswamy.
I work at MUFG, manage the enterprise data
and then do the data strategy
for the team right now.
- Fantastic, fantastic.
I had an opportunity
before we got started.
I always love to do this. So,
I walked the room a little bit
just to kinda get a
pulse for who's in here
and what the interest is,
and we have a, I won't point names,
but I've got some chief
product officers over here,
people that are in charge of product.
I've got teams on this
side that we talked to
that were really interested
in driving adopting
on the business side, really
pushing business self-service,
and those are two great topics.
Poor Raja's gonna have to work around me.
What we wanna do today here,
kind of in the conversation is
really bring to light the importance
of letting your business
teams really feel empowered
when they're driving the AI solutions.
And AI is very generic,
and I'm talking more on the GenAI side.
I'm talking more on the Agentic side.
I'm talking more about the
kind of conversational AI.
Maybe it's a bit more simpler.
I'm not talking machine learning.
I'm not gonna let my business
teams kind of drive ML ops,
but I do think when we get
business teams more involved
on actually being creative,
owning the art of the possible
with our AI capabilities, magic happens,
and a lot of the customers
and business teams
that I work with, I'm working
directly with business teams,
getting them excited,
building solutions together.
If you sat in on any of the
cloud sessions this morning,
it's amazing, right?
It feels so easy.
The ability to create,
the ability to build,
the ability to understand
how skills come together
to solve a solution.
These are all things
that our business teams
should be able to own
and drive on their own,
but there's a gap, right?
There's a gap that maybe it's
where some companies struggle
to drive that empowerment,
and that gap really comes down
to understanding your data
and being able to access your data, right?
And so, I kinda draw this
up in three simple blocks,
and Raja is down kind of
the journey over at MUFG,
and so what I wanna do
here is I wanna kinda
set the foundation for the talk track
in three simple layers,
and then I wanna dig
into Raja's experience
and what they're doing at MUFG
and the work they're doing to drive
business-driven AI innovation, right?
But let's start with the foundation first.
The first part of any foundation,
as I said a second ago,
the challenge is getting the data.
What we do is we allow our teams
to get data where it sits, right?
So I don't care if it's in the cloud,
I don't care if it's prem.
I prefer it to be in the lake.
It isn't always in a lake.
But Federation for a long
time is always what kinda
made Starburst famous, right?
That's what we've been
good at for a long time,
and that's great,
but if I can get to my data where it sits
without having to migrate
it, whether it's in the cloud
or on-prem, this next block is
what's most exciting, right?
And now you're hearing
a lot of excitement.
You're hearing a lot of buzz
around the semantic layer.
It's this business-facing semantic layer
that's the real game changer.
If I can access my data where
it sits without migrating it,
and I can start to organize
that data into logical data products
that my business teams can understand,
I told Raja this once before,
I said, "We wanna create
an experience when the business
teams walks in the room,
they recognize their data."
It's like walking in a family.
You know your cousins,
you know your family.
- Yep.
- You recognize your data.
It's easy for you to understand.
When you can create these
logical data products,
now, I don't care where the
data sits, I can organize it
into packages that my
business can understand,
it's a real game changer.
It's a true semantic layer
where you're abstracting
the legacy complexity
and you're giving the business
team something they can use.
And when you've done that,
now, business teams feel
a little bit more comfort.
Now, business teams feel
a lot more confidence
when they enter the room
and they say, "Look, I wanna
test out a new agent in Amazon.
I wanna test out a new agent
in any system. I just
need to get the data."
If they can ideate very quickly
because they can say, "I
need a little bit of this,
a little bit of this,
a little bit of this.
I wanna bring these governed, curated,
secure data products into my agent
and I wanna use them to
do an analytical exercise,
I can do that because
the data is already there
and I have the access in terms of security
and availability that
I need to get there."
Those are the three layers.
If you wanna think about what's the bridge
to get to business enablement for AI,
it's getting access to the
data through Federation.
It's creating a
business-facing semantic layer
that they understand.
In many cases, I build these
with the business teams.
Raja'll tell you, we've been building this
with his business teams,
and the third layer is in just
adopting these data products, right?
Using 'em directly in BI or AI solutions.
That's kind of the framework
that I like to talk about.
You don't wanna hear it from me,
you wanna hear it from Raja.
(Raja chuckles)
So, I apologize
for the long intro, Raja,
but I've set the stage.
- Yep.
- Before I kinda
jump into some questions,
is there anything you would correct
or anything you would add
to what I just talked about
in that foundation?
- I would say data needs
AI and AI needs data.
You know what I mean?
- Love it.
- It's a cycle.
So, I think I would say,
we started the journey,
like the traditional data strategy
where we'll consolidate everything
into physical consolidation,
move the data, curate the data,
profile the data, and then
do things accordingly.
We pivoted that and then
said, "Okay, can we create
data products in a logical way?"
And then those data products,
or what Adrian talked about, I will add is
the semantic layer is nothing but
from a business product
lens in a corporate world,
if you're from corporate
banking, you have lending,
like we have term loans, several
of those business products,
we aligned our business products
and data products to be identical,
so when a business user comes in,
there are business data producers
who create these curated data sets
from the semantic layer
so that they can create,
if, let's say we have
commercial loan operations,
that team wants to see the data
quality of the loan booking.
They are able to really curate the data
from the core products,
and then create a functional data model
or a data product that
is specific for them.
So, we gave the business users,
we created three personas
to Adrian's point,
business data producers.
We call them specifically
business data producers,
not IT or a CDO, am I right?
The data elites are in with the business,
so they know and speak the same language
that they can understand the data,
so I would add that for
us, it was more towards
how do we enable business
for self-sufficiency.
They should not be coming to IT
or data elites to understand
what data is there,
how it is related to the product,
how do I get access to that data?
So, this Starburst
provided us that capability
to pull data from multiple data sources,
whether it is distributed
environment, whether it is SaaS,
whether it is PaaS, whether
it is embedded systems
like Salesforce or any of those,
so we pulled that data in to create
the curated data products.
That enabled business for
them to be self-service.
- Perfect.
Was there a trigger, Raja,
that kinda, I don't wanna say forced,
but really kinda got you guys
to rethink your data strategy?
At what point did you guys say,
"Look, we've gotta do something different.
We have to maybe move
closer to the business.
We have to drive more self-service.
We have to find a way to
get our business teams
to trust more data." I don't
wanna give you the answers,
but (chuckles)-
- Yeah.
- What was the trigger at MUFG
to kind of force you to
rethink your old data strategy?
- I think time to market was the key.
How do we enable...
Because businesses making money as of now,
how do we in increase our
revenue generators' capability,
who are sitting within the
business, time to market?
Like how soon can we get the data
for them to prepare
the data for themselves
rather than they coming
to IT, I'm from IT,
coming to IT or CDO.
How do we enable the
business to prepare the data
to be self-sufficient?
That was the pivotal point
that triggered us to be in this journey.
- Love it.
Let's give the audience an idea
of what a semantic layer might look like,
without giving away too
many of your secrets,
and so I'm gonna stay high level here.
When I talk about a semantic layer
that business teams can understand,
and then, forgive me, you
stop me if I go too far.
Within MUFG, we've got this
notion of core data products
and functional data products.
You can think about the
functional data products
as derivatives of the core.
Core data products are well curated.
I got data from maybe a hundred sources
and I've organized them into a small set
of core data products.
I've got one for customer,
I've got one for channel,
I've got one banking, I've
got one for like kind of
all my different big things,
and then functional,
you can imagine having
a lending team saying,
"I need a little bit of that
one, a little bit of that one,
a little bit of that one,
to make this data product,
and that a little..."
And so they're building
their own derivatives
in their function to kinda
answer their specific
functional questions or analytical needs,
so to speak, right?
So, that's a model that
we're building at MUFG.
Now, tell me about your consumer,
your business teams on the function side.
Do they feel empowered?
Are they all jumping in,
or how is that working?
I didn't mean to do that. My
kids would go crazy, but...
(Raja laughs)
(Adrian laughs)
- It's a journey.
- Yeah.
- We have mixed
business users.
Some are very excited to see the data.
Some are like, "Okay,
get me halfway through.
I need to understand the data."
So we mixed up that with
data literacy programs
so that we can educate what data is there,
how they can access.
So it's mixed, like 50 50.
I would say some of the
users who are power users,
they are like, "Okay, I have my data
where I need from 50
different systems. I'm happy."
And then they can sail on their own.
They are self-sufficient.
- We're empowering business teams
to organize data in the
way that they need to.
Now, let's go back to the
third box, the AI box, right?
'cause that's kinda what we
really wanna talk about here.
If I can build a data
product that's curated,
the secret is business metadata.
It'd be one thing if
I'm just building data
from technical metadata.
- Yep.
- If I build a data product
with business metadata
at the column level,
at the table level, at the role level,
I've got real business
descriptions of that data product.
When you put that in front of an LLM,
you get very accurate analytics,
you get very performant analytics,
and so we can sit down
with a business team,
a lending team for example,
and say, "Here's your lending
data product. Go for it."
And it's not that you're
just giving them a solution
that they're gonna own forever.
You're giving them a capability
that they're going to evolve.
You want your business teams
to be able to look at the capability
and say, "Wait a minute, can it do this?
Can it do this? What if I add this skill?
What if I add that skill?"
The magic happens when the business teams
understand the data, and
they get the confidence
to work with AI.
They're not afraid to break something,
because in a data product,
you're only exposing this data.
That's it. Nothing else.
In a locked-in system,
there's really clear,
I love your three Gs.
What are your three Gs?
- Guidance, guardrails, and governance.
- You're giving 'em the
guardrails and the governance
and the guidance to experiment,
and so at the end of the day,
you're decreasing the time to experiment
and you're lowering
the cost to experiment.
So, I always say, I wanna do
10 AI projects in 10 weeks
versus one AI project in 18 months, right?
And they're all going to succeed,
but you can succeed on the three
and keep going forward
and fail on the seven.
If that's the, that's probably
not the right failure, right,
we all want, but that's the reality
when you're experimenting.
Not everything works.
On the AI side, Raja, I know
that we're just kinda starting
to build that foundation
for those data products.
How are you looking at the
Agentic front end to this
in the future?
- I think we are looking
at the AI landscape in two forms.
One is to make use of
all the data management,
enable the data management capabilities,
whether it is profiling,
whether it is lineage
or any of those.
Second part is we want our business users
to start chatting with the data.
We want our business users to say,
"Okay, can you give me
all the middle-market
banking customers."
We wanted to provide them that capability,
and then we provide them that list.
We also make sure that we integrate that
with our authentication mechanism.
We don't want middle-market
banking customers
to be exposed to who is
not authorized to do it,
so it's a mix of getting the chat,
using AI to enable data products,
get the lineage, get the
profiling, get the cataloging,
tagging, those kind of things.
That's part one, because
by having Starburst,
what's happening is it's enabling us
to go into one location, rather
than 50 different systems
that we have to go and do that across.
The other part of is people can,
as soon as they come to
Starburst, they can click on it.
We want to invoke the
chatting with that data,
using the Agentic
features that is available
to us, using Amazon
Bedrock and other features,
where everything is in one box
so that they can come to something called
real data marketplace.
So, that's kind of the objective of that.
- There's a point that I
wanted to underscore there,
'cause it's agility on the two sides.
If I have a semantic layer that I built
with my business teams, and
the semantic layer, logical,
doesn't care where the data comes from.
You can leave it there.
You can connect to it.
It's also the agility on the
front of that semantic layer,
saying, "I can build an agent."
I mean, if you look around
here, there's so many cool AI
or Agentic-type solutions, right?
If I'm a CEO, I wanna try them all,
but if every one of them is attached
to some core platform, it's expensive.
If every one of them requires me
to go model data a certain
way, it's expensive.
If I can deliver data
products to any agent,
and I can tell my business
teams, "I've got the guardrails,"
I'm gonna steal this from you,
"Got the governance and the guidance.
I will deliver the data to you."
Maybe you can build, you
can try any agent you want
on the front end, I don't care.
Build any agent. I'm gonna make
sure you get the right data.
Use any source, I'm gonna
make sure I connect to it
in the right way.
It's just incredible flexibility
and incredible agility
and ultimately offers you at longer term,
the opportunities to make better choices.
- Yep. Yeah.
What I would add is in this journey,
business plays a pivotal role.
Business is in partnership with us
for us to enhance the data
capabilities across the board,
and that comes by, I would say
it's a trust-building scenario
where we allow them to prepare data,
and also, it's a centralized location
where you have all the data
that you can really curate,
get things to the next level.
In fact, we improve our
data quality indexes
by pulling data through Starburst so that
when it's fed into any AI for modeling,
it has much more rich data quality.
- I like what you said earlier,
we were talking, you said,
"I use AI for data
and I use data for AI."
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Can you explain that a little bit?
- Yeah, so, when I say I use data for AI,
is to learn through the LLM models,
the entire content that is rich content
that we have in the organization.
Whether it is structured data
sitting in our deal file,
whether it is, sorry, unstructured data
that is sitting in our deal file,
or structured data that is in our systems,
so that data, we can feed it into AI
for learning more about the insights.
The other side is where
we need AI for data,
we wanted to use AI for tagging purposes.
We want to use for AI
for lineage creation.
We want to use AI for profiling.
So, those are the insights
that we can create.
So data for AI and AI for data.
- Love it. I love it.
- Yeah.
- Fantastic. Fantastic.
I'm gonna pause to see if
I've got any questions.
(crowd drones)
Awesome. Thank you very
much for your time.
Really appreciate your interest.
- Thank you.
- We have a booth,
just down the hall here at 550.
Happy to talk some more.
- Yeah, thank you. Thank you guys.
(crowd applauds)
Thank you.